Travel is an altered state of
consciousness I think that when we
travel what we are after is Altera T
what we are after is a defamiliarize in
shock the same kind of shock that's
necessary for aesthetic appreciation
objects of beauty by design are strange
they are different from the everyday in
other words we need to be catapulted
into noticing something we haven't seen
before and that requires this D
contextualization from the everyday thus
travel being an altered state of
consciousness because when you travel
you're leaving everything you know
behind all your conceptual maps about
reality all the rules and framework
related to the normal world in which you
dwell are upended when you are exposed
to a different culture when you are
exposed to a different language and all
of a sudden that defamiliarization right
that sense of first sight unencumbered
by knowingness it hurls you into the
present it puts you into a state of flow
into a state of openness you don't carry
around that screen of preconceptions
that been theirs and done that to the
adult mind travel travel in essence
functions very much like the museum a
museum takes ordinary objects or ideas
and removes them from context that hangs
them on a wall all art does that and by
removing the ordinary the everyday
object from its context you're able to
see it as it for the first time you're
able to contemplate it without its usual
wallpaper without its usual backdrop a
great example might be this ship hull I
have behind me right now see this hull
the front of the ship removed from
context placed as an art installation
piece behind me all of a sudden takes on
a quality that is incredibly novel that
is incredibly arresting it can be it can
be it can be beholden you can behold the
object removed from its familiar sort of
framing and so what that does I don't
know it awakens curiosity and awakens
wonder it awakens contemplative
introspection this is the function of
art this is the fun
of alterity this is the function of
travel it's about consciousness it's
about seeing the world differently and
the cognitive benefits that those kinds
of experience that that kind of
privileged perception affords us that's
what it's about
you